[موسيقى]
على كنا نعود للرياض ومراسله مساء العربيه
هناء نور اهلا بك يا هناء رمضان كريم
نتحدث اليوم عن الروبوت الالي في الشوارع
العاصمه الرياض الذي يقدم الوجبات
للسائقين حديثنا اكثر عن المشهد حولك
اهلا سهام اهلا نديم بارك عليكم الشهر في
مبادره جديده من نوعها روبوت يقوم بمساعده
المتطوعين في توزيع وجبات الافطار
للصائمين
وتجهيزها ولم يكتفي بذلك ايضا بل قام ايضا
بتوعيه الناس بعبارات توعويه عن اهميه حفظ
الطعام وعدم هدره هذه المبادره تقوم بها
وقف شباب خير امه والذي سيتحدث عنها اكثر
الامين العام لوقف شباب خير امه للاعمال
التطوعيه السيد خالد العوامري اهلا بك سيد
خالد بدايه نرى روبوت ويطلق عليها ليزا
كما ذكرت لي فنرى ليزا تقوم بمساعده
المتطوعين في تجهيز وتوزيع الوجبات وايضا
توعيه الناس كيف خطرت فكره اشراك الليزا
او الروبوت في هذه المبادره اوج نرحب
بالساده المشاهدين معنا اليوم عشان يعيشون
اجواء مبادرتنا النوعيه احنا عندنا كل سنه
مبادره نوعيه السنه هذه استهدفنا التوعيه
بتقليل كميات الهادر في توزيع وجبات افطار
صائم تحمل على عبارات اوعيه واخترنا
الروبوت الليزال يكون ايقونه المبادره
ويوصل الفكره بشكل اسهل ومنها برضو توظيف
التقنيه والذكاء الاصطناعي في مجال
المبادرات الطوعيه وفي مجال العمل التطوعي
والمجال الخيري بشكل عام اخترنا الشخصيه
الايقونه هذه الجميله اللي معنا اليوم
لازاع علشان تقدم وتساعد المتطوعين في نقل
الوجبات بين الاماكن التعبئه واماكن
التوزين مثل ما انتم شايفين تنتقل بعدها
الى الاشارات في التوزيع عندنا ثلاث نقاط
توزيع على مستوى مدينه الرياض توصل عن
طريقها العبارات بلغتها الالكترونيه
العبارات التوعويه التي تقلل من كميات
الهدر نستهدف من خلالها انه نقلل بكميات
الهيدر في الطعام وننشر الوعي في هالنقطه
المهمه اللي قاعدين احنا نعالجها في
مبادرتنا اذا سيد خالد كيف تلقى الناس او
ما هي ردود افعالهم على استخدام روبوت
يقوم بمساعده المطوعين في توزيع وجبات
الافطار وتوعيه النازل احنا صراحه كانت
التجربه الاولى مع شركائنا في شركه نظم
الرياض لتقنيه المعلومات لكن بعد ما شفنا
الردود الافعال الكبيره وكيف ان الناس
قاعدين يتفاعلوا معنا وينزلون عشان يصورون
مع الروبوت او حتى انهم يسمعون الكلام
اللي قاعد ينطق به في هذا دليل بس على
نجاحنا احنا من هالفكره ان شاء الله باذن
الله راح نطور مبادرتنا التقنيه وكيف انه
نستخدم نوظف التقنيه في مجال المبادره
التوعيه مع شركاء في شركه نظم الرياض
وبيكون باذن الله سنوات القادمه تصنيع
المثلها الروبوت هنا في المملكه عن طريق
الشركه الله يعطيهم العافيه وبنظفها بشكل
اكبر في المبادره التطوعيه والعمل
التطوعيه
اليد والان نتجه الى ليزا لنرى كيف تقوم
بالتوزيع الوجبات ومساعده المتطوعين
[موسيقى]
يعني لذا بكامل نشاطها وهي تقوم اذا
بمساعده المتطوعين ضمن هذه المبادرات
الرمضانيه شكرا لك يا هناء وشكرا ايضا لكل
الجميع وشكرا لليزا سلامات لالك ولاليزا
الى اللقاء